bonjour alors aujourd'hui on va remonter
le temps je vous amène dans un petit
bistrot qui est nichée au pied d'une
abbatiale qui a plus de mille ans nous
sommes à beaulieu-lès-loches dans le sud
de la touraine
suivez-moi finul dans un produit fini la
philosophie levés lui maintenant au
boulot
non mais je suis dit quand je suis
arrivé il ya 39 ans j'étais un jeune
couillon après on traiter de vieux cons
humaine maintenant je subis dit eh bien
c est un peu luxueux bateau merci site
web je suis très judicieux aujourd'hui
j'ai amené la terrine de cerf le cerf a
été fourni l'avion n'a été fournie par
monsieur et moi j'ai fait la mise en
oeuvre et pour la mise en bouche qui
s'en occupera la mise en bouche bat
serena celui qui voulait participer
cellex c open
et pour vous j'ai mon nom qui a été
grand reporter à paris match j'en ai
marre de philo et puis j'ai eu un
accident aux foules du coup je me suis
retrouvé avec mon enquête et grand
reporter à paris match qui m'a dit bah
c'est un copain qui montrent un resto de
luxe match et il a des serveurs et tous
les quinze jours et les virils il en
cherche à nous suivre
moi je veux bien faire un essai il
écoute
je me suis retrouvée au bout de deux
mois c'était moi qui étais moi chef du
restaurant c'est moi qui commande et
whoopi j'avais des carliers me la couler
machin les ligues brasseur les bêlements
d'où les machins tous les milliardaires
qui venait et du coup mon père a voulu
comme on était tous comment était
d'origine auvergnate les auvergnats
étaient tous des bougnats des machins
des des restaurateurs du coude a voulu
acheter le truc tu une grand mère qui
venait chappuis est bon du coup on s'est
dit on va leur prendre c'est sur leur
place
on a fait faire une terrasse où le pays
va une tablée de l'ampleur et via les
vedettes robin a maintenant tu mets mon
ami me gêne york avant au moins 12 me
voir il parlait il a raconté qu'il
venait manger ici les les meilleurs
omelette aux champignons qui j'ai beau
du monde
oh laissera sourire de plats du
jour direct voulez du vin de la bière et
s1 2010 comme il ya pu y est plus grand
chose il ya plus beaucoup d'animations
c'est un point de rencontre c'est ça qui
est agréable on rencontre des gens de
tout de tout horizon que toutes
conditions c'est sympa parce que les
gens qui viennent les touristes les des
locaux c'est très divers
et vos mangas et ben je dis ça une âme
effectivement parce que par la diversité
de son groupe par le fas le patron que
déjà parlé par lui-même c'est un
personnage assez assez atypique curieux
d'un monsieur qui a quand même deux
tempéraments des connaissances et puis
delà des qualités humaines et aussi les
tempéraments différents
ah oui malgré sa boutique oui il a des
humeurs un temps d'enfin d'accès
c'est toujours ça les robes et les
grands travaux les uns d'entre eux si
vous arrivez ici sans lui dire bonjour
là vous allez être maître vu c'est pas
sûr qu'il engage la conversation
la première des choses c'est une règle
qui d'ailleurs je ne conteste pas c'est
la politesse gilles à eau pure et à
stevie wonder
quand il ya 40 ans tu es sage il dit
sans innover en maintenant ses 20 ans
environ et toute aide est transformé on
s'est fait baiser
le rock c'est bien tous les quinze jours
dans un kit nu et qui te font une
nouvelle norme disait tu mettras un
pointu sinon y avait le ballon
ben verbal horreur là les mecs les mecs
buvait un ballon tac
alors c'était un début un pointu sinon
tu veux un bon jeu pour l'aider à coup
traitée la même quantité mon vieux je te
fais l'expérience
c'était la même quantité
sauf que le verbe est un peu plus de
style ah oui est en avril prenait avec
le petit doigt en l'air
j'attends des années j'ai des amis ça a
été au bout du
m j'attends des amis là il ya eu une
goutte qui tombe et à côté il est très
bon un velours de lestonnac 2010 et
voulait de la salle à deux avec le grand
que madame les deux avec salade
donc quoi qu'il fasse et comment le
préserve après gilles là justement là
parce que ça va pas loin de quarante ans
qu'il est là mais c'est le bon la tâche
qui ont l'empêchent de partir en fait
[Musique]
eh ben je veux partir en floride mais il
y en a plus au revoir
musique ça recommence comme ils disent à
wimbledon you boys on recommence
balles neuves
maintenant je suis un bouchon lyonnais
de campagne mais je gagne moins cher
qu'avant et la vie est moins facile
scepticisme